so you have three hundred thousand
dollars of credit cards and personal
loans we have
and credit cards forty four thousand
personal loans and thirty five thousand
car loans
okay
um how old are you
I am 29.
so what in the world
[Music]
I mean are you both on this or is this
just one of you that's completely lost
your mind well I have the majority of
the student loans and he has the
majority of the of the credit cards my
credit card debt is about it's not great
why is he at 29 years old run up 100
Grand in credit card debt well he's he's
32 but
um I I think it's one of those things
where just making really poor financial
decisions thinking be able to pay it
down as you go and then it doesn't it
doesn't happen